皆様は
ブーブークッションという物を
ご存知だろうか
どんな物かといいますと
上に乗ると
乗ってみましょう
下品だな...あ、うぇーー
襟立てたらこの服かっこいいな
今見てもらった通りだ
下品な音がするだろう
そうだ
下品だ
まあ、このブーブークッションなんですけども
同時に音を出すと音が大きくなるわけなんですけど
何個まで音が大きくなるかというのをやろうと思ったんだけども
まあちょ見ててくださいよ
1個でやってみます
2個
3個
4個
5個
6個
はっはっ
7個
8個
9個
ここまで大きくなるとバランス的に難しくなるんですよ
こうやって乗っても
ほらもう何個か脱落ファイア
という感じで中々難しくなってしまいます
よってブーブークッションは最大9個くらいしか鳴らせません
残念ですね
じゃあな！
う”う”う”－－－
まあまあ普通の人間ならここで終わってしまうだろう
私は違う
そう
私は思いついてしまった
そうです、これバランスが悪いんですよ
重ねれば重ねるほど高さが出ちゃって
全てのブーブークッションがバランス良く真ん中重心捉えられて
キレイにプレスされるとは限らないので
滑っちゃったりして落ちるわけですよブーブークッションが
つまり、ブーブークッションを同時に9個以上鳴らせることは限りなく不可能である
普通にやればね
そこで私はひらめいた
そうです、バランスを取ればいいのです
というわけで今回こちらを準備しました
こちらです！
バケツ、バケツでございます
私はひらめいてしまった
このバケツの中にブーブークッション入れます
ほらもうバッチリぴったり
ブーブークッションとバケツの直径がぴったりです
このバケツの中にブーブークッション3つくらい入れて
バケツを置いて私が乗ると
ていう感じに音が出ます
今の原理を利用して
というわけで今回
これねあのね簡単に見えてホントに難しいからね
ブーブークッション全部同じタイミングで鳴らすのって
ホントせいぜい8個9個くらいが限界なので
何個？何個あるの？
40個くらいあるかもしれないよ
40個のブーブークッションが全く同じタイミングで鳴る事なんて多分
ないよ
ほんとにほんとに今日は多分ねすごい
歴史に残る実験をやろうと思ってるので
是非皆さん全てのブーブークッションが全く同じタイミングで鳴る瞬間を
その目で確かめてみてください
ではいこう
では早速置いていきます
うわああ
バランス悪いよ～
バランス悪いね
バランス悪い
待てよ、でも結局
ちょっとここ開けて
この隙間に入れたらバランス崩さない気がする
これはいけるっしょ
うぇい
うわあああああ
完成しました
こちらが
某ドンキに売っていたブーブークッションを詰め合わせた
全部が同時に音が鳴るブーブークッション椅子です
ブーブークッションバケツです
これで僕が一番上に乗って
乗った瞬間　全てのブーブークッションが
同じタイミングで音が鳴るというわけでございます
あの、ここから乗っちゃうと
こういう動きになっちゃうからダメなんで
もう勢いつけて僕がここに飛び乗ります
そしたら壁にこう力が行くので
こういうかかり方
こういうかかり方になって　このまま下に行くんで
これで完全に音が鳴ります
3,40人ぐらいが同じタイミングでその時を迎えることなんてないですから
奇跡のハーモニーを是非お楽しみください
フィナーレだ！
いきます
3,2,1
怖い怖い
乗ればいいんだよね、乗れば勝ち
いきます
3,2,1
ちょっと待ってw